you had a video for your J Fingers
Youtube channel on late bloomers and one
thing I found interesting was a comment
that was underneath the video and that
was someone put that age 35 was a sweet
spot for screenwriters I thought that
was interesting any thoughts on that
yeah I um
I I saw that comment and I kind of
agreed with it
um
you know uh I I
felt that if I'd continued you know on
on my you know trajectory had I not
taken like that little break or whatever
um or had I like maybe moved out to LA
sooner that I probably would have found
success at around 35
um so I agreed with that sentiment uh
and I think I I think there's a there's
some truth to that you know because when
you're in your 20s you know you're
you're young and dumb you know I was you
know I certainly thought that oh this is
you know this is gonna happen and this
is and of course things don't turn out
that way
um but by the time you reach your 30s
you've got a certain amount of life
experience
that I think uh I think that life
experience is is absolutely necessary
you know for screenwriting
um and I think that you've got the
necessary life experience by that point
and it's right before I think the
industry starts to look at you in a
certain way
because uh
I mean if we're going to be honest
ageism is a thing
and I
I know that there are successful
screenwriters you know who in their 40s
50s 60s and and Beyond but I do think
that
um that people
may look at an emerging screenwriter of
a certain age you know kind of like
why you know why has it taken you this
long it could be for any variety of
reasons you know I certainly know
screenwriters who decided that they
didn't want to pursue screenwriting
until they were in their 50s and that's
fantastic you know if they've got the uh
uh uh the talent and the drive and you
know they can certainly succeed but I do
think that there's there's a bit of
ageism you know that comes into play so
35 is is
definitely the sweet spots it's it's
before you you get looked at but
after you've got the life experience and
you know what you're doing
when did you start feeling that writing
screenplays wasn't enough to advance
your career
it's really that's that's
a recent feeling
um yeah because for a long time I
thought that that's all I had to do
just write a screenplay and then
that's it you know everyone's coming to
me you know I've got the I've got the
gold right
um
okay
so yeah I I've really though just just
come to realize that
I've probably got to do more
that may entail like making a short film
which is uh something that that I'm
thinking of doing
um
but yeah they're they're I just have to
find other ways to just kind of
stand out uh get my work out there
um
I've got to figure it out yeah
what new strategies are you thinking of
for moving your screenwriting career
forward you talked about possibly doing
a short film right right which uh for me
that's like that's the biggest thing
uh simply because
it will showcase my writing but it's
also something that you know people can
see you know I think a short film people
I think that people are a lot um
more receptive to watching a 10-minute
short film than they are sitting down
with a hundred page screenplay
uh and I just think that you know that
can something like a short film can get
my strengths as a writer across you know
with dialogue and character development
all those things
um
aside from that you know just really
trying to uh to network you know just
make sure that I'm out there
um to build community you know speak
with people
um I think that's really the important
thing is is to to really just kind of
like build that community
um
because this is a business that's built
on relationships
and
you know
someone knows someone that can help
then maybe a connection can be made you
know and I don't I mean I don't mean
that like a selfish way you know I'm not
just trying to make friends just to you
know
break in but that's just the way the
world works
and I've always been like that I've
always always been the type of person to
connect and help whenever I can so I
just need to uh I feel I just need to
ramp that up a little more
as far as uh
screenwriting in film is concerned
do you think at some point
it's wise though to fly the coop I mean
groups are great and and it's wonderful
to have supportive people and it is a
business of relationships but then at
some point to just know that it's the
engine of Jay that has to
get this out oh absolutely yeah yeah
yeah
um you know I feel that the group is
great so that you know we have that base
and we have that Community but I also
think that the expectation is that we
will fly off you know into you know our
own directions and create our own paths
um
I mean it it'd be awesome if someone in
the group you know is able to you know
turn around and reach back and pull
someone up you know I would love to you
know help someone out uh in the group if
I ever can
but like I said you know I think that
it is expected for us to to kind of go
out and do our our own thing
with your Mentor Jay are there things
that he's been teaching you about the
business not just craft that have been
helpful to you
yeah the the biggest thing is is to just
be aware of the business of the business
you know
um to ensure that you've got a great
team in place uh you're going to want
your manager and and agent
and or agent but you're also going to
want to have a great accountant you're
going to want to have you know a great
attorney you know and an attorney that
knows entertainment law
uh you know just make sure that you
understand the contracts you know the
deals that you're you're signing into
you know you don't have to because
League leases is a whole other language
of its own so you know you don't have to
know like the entire like you know 50
page contract or whatever but at least
understand what it entails you know what
people are expecting you know of you
um what are your expectations make sure
that they're laid out and make sure that
you know your wants are covered as well
those have been the the biggest things
how often this might happen to a new
writer where something else is in the
Zeitgeist at the same time gets made and
there's a feeling of what if that was my
script
I mean
I don't
I honestly don't know
really that that happens often uh
I always hear
that it's cheaper to just buy the script
you know than to steal the idea or steal
the script you know because litigation
and this that and the other
so yeah I mean I honestly don't hear
very many stories at all of screenplays
being stolen or ideas being being stolen
it's just one of those things that that
happens
um I do believe I I solve a video uh
film courage video oh I can't remember
the uh the filmmaker's name but he did
say that he had an experience where his
script was stolen and you know he talked
about what he would have done
differently
um
but I I honestly feel just based on
you know what I've heard and everything
I just honestly feel that that's not
that commonplace maybe that's just my
naivete
you know coming to the fore but uh yeah
I don't I don't
I honestly don't have a like fear of
stolen ideas or screenplays